political strength grew his relations
what follows
the greatest froze black marketeers and
grand-scale dope pushers
I could do it tomorrow I could do next
week I could do it the week after and I
could maybe just hang on to the
documents and never do anything about it
just sit by and let time go on but the
thing that I'm overpowered with totally
overpowered with is the fact that this
very moment we're killing people in
Vietnam with our tax dollars as a result
of our
when I came into possession of these
papers I looked around and nobody in
government had done anything the only
thing that was being done in government
there's an effort to stifle and hide
this stuff and it just done done made it
somebody if ur get you're going to have
any faith at all in our institutions
somebody from governments got to be
gonna have the same resolve the same
feelings for for stopping and killing as
Ellsberg did as the post bit as the New
York Times did as the st. Louis
post-dispatch as all these jerk I only
myself because the people who released
it for bureaucrats you know bureaucrats
the people who disparage so often they
weren't elected officials they are
bureaucrats and and they have much less
risk than I have the risk that I have is
being exposed from the Senate
so how many press people sitting at the
at this side of the table that I think
things things have changed with the
media the Fourth Estate probably shows
the activities of the New York Times and
The Washington Post and a few others the
through this was developed with certain
arrogance I don't know
we're developing ethical
please could I could fund
yes the reason I am using this vehicle
but I am not immune to censure or
exposure
back daughter
congressman I want to thank you very
very personally and the state in a very
unusual fashion something that there
should be noted for history that is that
the first time you and I met was when we
a few hours ago shook hands at this
witness table I am acquainted with your
record I know that you were one of the
early ones back in May of 1965 to oppose
our involvement in Vietnam I know what
that opposition has cost you as a person
to this committee
the time to focus on me for a second
I have to say that I have been seriously
concerned about American involvement in
Vietnam from the very beginning I think
it was dead wrong and I think those of
us who felt that way at that time have
been vindicated I guess that's about all
I can say I'm not trying to crawl or
anything I'm not trying to say I told
you so but I think if we've had this
conviction such as you and I hold I
think we've got to keep on we've got to
keep up the and I repeat again what's
wrong with this nation and what's that
issue at this particular point in our
history is not the fact that the
American people have lost faith and
trust in its leaders but the very simple
fact that over the last 20 years up to
today the American leadership has not
demonstrated has not had the faith and
trust in the American people and had
that faith and trust and
straightforwardness been present this
nation would not be in the mess it's in
today and these papers that I'm reading
bring that case out more clearly than I
could ever write it the Pentagon it's in
three tiers I'm reading summaries of
narratives the narratives are based upon
the documents themselves the congressman
if you'll permit me I'll continue to
read and I'd like to make a right now I
just like to offer one sentence senator
and that is if the backed by the United
States DM refused and I think these are
important lines backed by the United
States DM refused to open consultation
with the North Vietnamese concerning
general elections when the date for
these fell due in July 19
by pressing scooter pressing his
military advantage against the sex he
moved to consolidate his position for
existing economic and financial
agreements with France and called upon
France to denounce the genesis of the
Geneva cor Accords and pursued an
international and domestic policy of
anti-communism both Viet Nam's took the
view that Ferrari but statements could
not gainsay the practical import of the
occur
okay
book covers pages where you can tell
I've kept that's that's all on this
that's being released tonight we're
releasing all this stuff to the press
tonight what is it do you have all the
Kennedy stuff tonight it's coming over
right now yeah where do we apparently -
I just go through it again apparently my
staff under my instruction this is
negotiated with the three wire services
to give you copies of these when I made
the motion to put in a record and we're
getting some more language so that I can
get the record proper that automatically
we think authorized me to you're going
to do this so you'll be getting these
three decades before the lights go I
tried to do that on the Senate floor I
was there Letterman I don't know how
long this will last
so I'm going to try and get as many
documents out as I can receive it why
did you decide to do it this way because
what it is I view the situation what
happened hey somebody released this
information I don't I don't know who I
read the newspapers like the rest of you
and watch TV and they say it's Daniel
Ellsberg and he apparently has confessed
I think he's done a service to this
country
he's on an island up there and I think
he's going to have an effect in ending
this war and I think the courage of the
newspapers to print what they did in the
face of the dangers that they face
economically and personally the
executives of these newspapers I think
is one of the great that I run I meant
about Accenture but well that's less how
do you know explosion was worse than
section what makes you think that you're
allowed to be exposed
expelled in the Senate for this but I
think he will judge those events as it
goes on
why did you decide to do it this way -
most fun because I as I understand my
legal rights of the United States
Senator by convening this committee I am
still immune
under other facets of the law that have
not made other people than you why did
you do it tomorrow morning what is she I
felt that it had I had to make do it
sometime senator there you must let me
just finish that one thought and I I
don't understand as a human being with
my mind justice to Symington coal very
simply that but the chief executive of
this country country probably spent
anywhere from 50 to 120 million dollars
without Congress knowing about it now
still signing the mind you sits on that
special committee is supposed to watch
the CIA now that the chief executive
this country did that hired thousands of
people in one country moved into another
country and then waged the war at the
border of China without anybody knowing
in Congress for the people as opposing
the Chinese people the Chinese
government decided to invade as a result
of that provocation then what would the
public record be that obviously they
attacked our troops and then them in the
documents because you get lost in the
nitty-gritty you get lost in it and the
incidentals of the day and and it's much
more important the document you mean to
keep well yeah yeah carry weight is
thousands of thousands of you the part
of you have these enjoy it and in the
air and I spent hours reading and all I
come away with to Houston with the the
gargantuan size of reading it and so I
could spend the next year reading I
could spend the next ten years reading
this stuff but but what counts is is
that somebody at the Pentagon perform
the study brought all these documents
together narrated all the documents
interrelated it and and this is a long
narrative and then on top of that so
that people in the Subcommittee on
buildings and grounds it's the only
chairmanship that I have and I treasure
it dearly
senator are you concerned that any legal
effort might be made to stop you from
making these documents public I think
that cadet that concern is obviously
there otherwise I wouldn't have what I
consider some of the finest
constitutional lawyers working for me to
help guide me in my decision process on
constitutional law you didn't come into
buildings and grounds wait to get them
there they're kind of a volunteer other
Vietnam that are they're retained by me
the Vietnam veterans we share a same
cause that is that they want to end the
war and I want to in the war the
information has to read him would have
been right on the floor in that chamber
but I was denied that right by the
Republican minority whip Robert Griffin
senator have your legal experts told you
that you're safe from any prosecution or
injunction as long as you read these in
your function as a subcommittee chairman
that's the that's the question yet to be
decided
Saturday you only hopes of is expecting
that the lately what they've told me is
that the question yet to be decided that
there is some possibility you could all
be enjoying legally there's yes as I let
me state again I'm not an attorney I
have no background in constitutional law
and
and we're just developing this
non-government concurrently the United
States began to channel aid directly to
South Vietnam rather than through France
the counter-revolution of French policy
then thrust upon the u.s. a choice
between supporting diem or the French
presence in Indochina the u.s. opted for
diem by the time the deadlines for
election consultations fell due in July
1950 pigeons are extremely vague but at
one point they are clear in stipulating
that the elections are to be free
everything will not as is often alleged
connive with diem to ignore the
elections Geneva Accords and his
opposition to pre-election consultations
were at his own initiative however the
US which had expected elections to be
held and up until May of 1955 had fully
supported them shifted its position in
the face of dm's opposition and of the
evidence very Dulles said that we did
not support the Geneva Accords who put
this together and and deal just in the
summary words itself this is a summary
itself and I would have to reread the
papers reevaluate him and to say
categorically that's correct it's my
impression reading it from this that
that is correct
mmm because the United States took a
position in support of the Geneva
Convention while we did not win by not a
signatory we had indicated in a separate
statement that we supported the Gini
invention as I recall it as has been
stated before congressman first this is
only one each to adherence in thing
about an accommodation in other ways it
wasn't a massacre of South Vietnamese
not at all
congressman I'd like to impose and get
into this record also and I'll stop at
this point in time to read the statement
I would have read on the floor of the
United States Senate had I been
permitted to read that's they've been on
the floor of the United States Senate
but I was denied the right that I
naively thought all senators had and I
must say the reason why I was denied
that right was because of my naivete
because obviously through Senate stopped
me from reading mr. president can anyone
doubt that we are agonized can anyone
doubt that these are a ghen izing times
for America can anyone doubt that this
nation is being torn apart by a war that
Sears its conscience a terrible shadow
of suspicion is across the land
suspicion that we have made a terrible
mistake that we have spent lives and
wealth in pursuit of an unworthy goal
suspicion that government has not been
influenced must be preserved preserved
so that Southeast Asia would not have a
communist government we supported the
French with American tax dollars to such
an extent that by the war's peak
Americans were paying eighty percent of
the total cost of the French war not not
the American or
that was a policy endorsed by American
leaders as a means of halting the spread
of communism without expending American
lives virtually without exception
American leaders have built upon those
policy origins provide blandly boldly
from through the doors that connect this
chamber with the outside world and I was
referring in this paper to the Senate
chamber and now I refer to this
committee chamber and the committee
system is part of Senate procedures and
house procedures and congressional
procedures and I'm proud to be sitting
here as a committee chairman of a humble
committee and proud to have before me
what I think is a great American a
congressman from New York I did not seek
these papers when they were offered I
accepted them I have reviewed the papers
in my possession and read much of the
material it is a remarkable work to say
the least
remarkable for what it says about those
who chew about those chiefly responsible
for managing our efforts in Southeast
Asia in 1967
it flow from full possession of the
facts they knew that we would achieve no
worthy goal and reap only the
consequences the study was tonight
right now we have these documents we
have them under the most stringent
circumstances imaginable mr. president
mr. congressman there is note that
people must know the full story of what
has occurred over the past 20 years
within their government the story is a
terrible one
it is replete with duplicity connivance
against the public and public officials
I know of nothing in our history to
equal it for extent of failure and
extensive loss in all aspects of the
term we can eople human beings are being
killed as I speak to you tonight killed
as a direct result of policy decisions
we as a body have made arms arms are
being served metal is crashing through
human bodies because of a public policy
this government
one may respond that we made such a
sacrifice to preserve a freedom and
liberty in Southeast Asia one may
respond that we sacrifice ourselves on
the continent of Asia so that we will
not have to fight a similar war on the
shores of America one can make these
arguments only if he has failed to read
the Pentagon Papers that is the terrible
truth of it all the papers do not
support our public statements the papers
do not support our best intentions the
papers prove that for twenty years and
certainly for the last ten years we have
a big press admiration for your courage
and you're certainly one individual who
hasn't knuckle under to the institutions
and the regimentation
that have become so great and so ominous
in our society I have one comment to
make about your presentation today and
that is that for most of us who have
followed the events in Southeast Asia
over the past 20 years
it've Department has itself made own
congressman the kid I want to thank you
in behalf of myself American people
let me just say that a sub